a community-based non-profit is working
to raise mental health awareness here in
clark county
teens from across nevada joined in on a
webinar today to talk about their
experiences with isolation during the
pandemic
and really start those tough but
necessary conversations
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
joined in on the webinar and spoke to
the leaders of that organization
she joins us now with the details
madison yes in recent months nevada has
seen a surge
in teen suicides that schools remain
closed due to the pandemic
so just recently the new york times
wrote an article about how kids in clark
county
are especially struggling hope means
nevada has made it its mission
to combat this not only starting a
conversation but continuing it
just in case you do need help reaching
out to someone teens from all over
nevada came together sunday afternoon to
take part in a hope means nevada web
seminar
the organization that focuses on
addressing mental health challenges
heard from several teens and officials
discussing their struggles
while in this pandemic just not having
that physical contact with people
i know as of like two days ago i believe
that ccsd canceled all of its sports
so not being able to have our season is
really
like it's really affecting us negatively
so
i think a lot of the escapes that we
used to have are just being taken away
from us
the youth suicide rate in clark county
is disturbing
as an article in the new york times
reported that 18 kids ended their lives
since the start of the pandemic in 2020.
isolation and confinement is hard for
anyone to go through
but for our youth it's causing them to
lose hope about their future
like missing events not only have we
been isolated and we're not having
social interaction and
uh things like that but we also feel
like we're missing out on
um kind of rights to passage in like
things like prom and homecoming nothing
is more important than the student
mental health
nevada senator marilyn dondero loop
joined in on the conversation
announcing that a mental health day bill
was on the horizon
this bill would allow students to take
time off if they were dealing with any
mental challenges
different from an ordinary sick day
overall the webinar was cathartic
bringing a sense of togetherness to the
teens and adults involved
having like friends and like having this
meeting and
caroline and lauren and it's like it's
nice to
have these people around and having like
such a big support group knowing that
like i'm not alone in this
and the organization will be hosting
another webinar this thursday entitled
youth mental health talk
we of course will have more information
on our website reporting in studio
madison kimbrough
8 news now